aujourd'hui on parle pas de rouille
aujourd'hui pas de vegas aujourd'hui pas
de new york aujourd'hui patty parle ça
pour faire par contre très très très
très prochainement ensemble je vous
emmène à amsterdam la semaine prochaine
dont je vous invite à vous abonner dès
aujourd'hui poursuivre en voyant les
trucs intéressants
du côté de syphilis pour parler de tv
d'audio ça va être vraiment cool et ya
plein de voyage de prévue bientôt dans
les mois à venir finalement c'est
vraiment cool ça je me sens pas plus
tard aujourd'hui on se concentrait
surtout qui m'intéresse beaucoup c'est
parler dow et on va parler du futur
smartphone flagship au niveau de la
photo faut savoir que la gamme p chez
huawei c'est la gamme photo et la gamme
mayte c'est la gamme performance n'a
donc eu le mec 30 pro il ya pas
longtemps qu'ils étaient vraiment le
smartphone le plus performant des
dernières techniques du côté de chez
huawei et on va avoir dix y aller un
mois et demi deux mois deux mois je
pense devoir le demander mais le nouveau
smartphone photo de chez huawei p 40 p
40 pro et 40 like et peut-être même un
autre modèle qui serait le paie 40 pro
édition premium
on aurait donc quatre nouveaux modèles
qui pourrait arriver de 3 sur l'année
dernière p 30 p 30 pro b 30 light
l'année dernière l'année d'avant
également que le pv en face à une chose
d'avoir peut-être quatre mots des autres
ce qui est vraiment très intéressant et
pourquoi s'intéresse à un très gros
focus sur la wii maintenant tout
simplement parce que moi on est un petit
peu dans le dur depuis quelques mois ne
vous aura pas échappé que l'on voit où
il ne peut pas utiliser les services
google il ya un problème au niveau entre
les usa et la chine
huawei en fait directement les frais et
du coup on ne peut pas avoir tous les
services google alors on a toujours un
androïde dix versions de base mais on
peut pas avoir le plextor peut pas avoir
de gmail on peut pas avoir youtube on
peut pas voir pleins d'applications et
c'est relativement embêtant vous ne déjà
parlé dans la vidéo test d'une mais 30
pro qui est un super modèle mais qui par
contre on ne bénéficiant pas de cerner
si tout ça un petit peu plus compliqué
on verra ce qu'on nous propose et huawei
avec cp 40 p 40 pro et compagnie voir
comment ce qu'ils avaient un petit peu à
solutionner tout ça pour l'instant moi
faire c'est qu'on va dégrossi un petit
peu le portrait robot du futur flagship
photos que c'est dur à dire flagship
photos de huawei qui a l'air une fois de
plus complètement énorme ce qui est
toujours hyper impressionnant chez ben
ouais c'est le gros boulot qu'ils font
du côté de la recherche développement et
un gros budget qui a loué en r&d
recherche et développement et du qu'on
le voit les résultats tomberont à des
smartphones qui sont énormes
l'année dernière avec le p 30 pro on a
vraiment tous été surpris tous pris une
petite claque avec la caméra
périscopique lemouneau que vous avez dit
laurent du coup derrière les effets vous
et derrière c'est vraiment hallucinant
donc je ne doute pas cette année avec un
p 40 pro huawei est encore plus loin
d'autant plus que là ils ont vraiment
heureux de montrer au monde entier qui
sont leaders dans leur domaine qui sont
tout cas capable d'innover d'innover
très fort et que bien qu'il ait pas de
service google eh bien il faut quand
même se poser la question d'aller sur
leur smartphone parce que tout
simplement on a des meilleurs
smartphones en termes de photos c'est
vraiment tout à tout le challenge pour
ce premier trimestre 2001 alors il ya eu
plein de fuite plein de licques et aussi
beaucoup de rumeurs qui circulent mais
déjà des rendus qui arrive sur internet
une tornade fait de dessiner les
contours de ce p 40 euros on aurait donc
un smartphone avec en tout sept capteur
photo seth capteur photo c'est énorme ce
un capteur à l'arrière deux capteurs
allemande de capteurs l'homme qui serait
en cas de fait dans une petit but un peu
comme ce qu'on avait sur le s10 plus on
aurait la caméra de l'autre côté on
l'aurait du côté gauche et non pas du
côté droit comme souvent oppose samsung
et à l'arrière vous auriez pas moins de
cinq capteurs alors on s'est pas
réellement sens honoré cinq capteurs
pastoraux édition spéciale ou alors
est-ce qu'on aurait quatre capteurs sur
une édition professionnelle et reste
quand même un petit doute qui plane
là-dessus entre ces deux modèles
toujours dit que si on le paie 40
projets modèles plus haut de gamme on
aurait cinq capteurs photo à l'arrière
ça je vous le dévoile dans quelques
instants
on aurait sur le modèle le plus haut de
gamme un dos tout en céramique à la
différence d'une maille 30 pro ou le
bouton de volume avait disparu il
fallait bien toucher le côté de l'écran
est bien là vous aurez effectivement un
bouton de volume physique comme ce que
vous avez sur le pétrin pro de l'année
dernière bien évidemment un capteur
d'empreinte sous l'écran pour les
brouilles et extrêmement rapidement une
techno que maîtrise parfaitement bien
huawei l'écran pareil devrait
complètement énorme on sait pas si on
aurait une dalle oled de 5 pouces ou de
6,7 pousse à priori quad hd plus un
écran 2d bords incurvés toujours plus
immersif et un écran de 120 hertz alors
je sais pas si vous avez suivi l'actu
120 hertz
c'est ce que nous a montrée en tout cas
au one plus ils ont annoncé qu'ils
allaient produire des smartphones et des
écrans 120 hertz avec des dalles samsung
est justement samsung soit son plus gros
modèles sont plus gros
est ce vin devrait pourrait intégrer un
écran 120 hertz alors qu'est ce que vous
apporte un écran standard et bien tout
simplement plus de fluidité lorsque vous
allez venir scrollé un meilleur confort
visuel
lorsque vous allez jouer l'expérience
sera significativement augmenté bien
évidemment tout ça pour le confort
visuel aussi pour le côté complètement
multimédia le multimédia justement serez
pas en reste avec des haut-parleurs
stéréo c'est faux si par contre il n'y
aurait pas deux prises jack pour vous
connecter à votre smartphone vous auriez
un petit adaptateur usb s'est prise jack
s'en retrouve déjà dans pas mal de
modèles personnellement je suis pas très
fan ce que je conseille à ce moment là
c'est passer par un casque en bluetooth
parce que justement on aurait du
bluetooth 5.1 bien évidemment beaucoup
de performances avec le dernier
processeur de silicone le crid 990 non
pour et j'imagine à lyon entre 8 à 12
giga de ram en fonction de la
configuration pourrait avoir est monté
jusqu'à 512 giga de stockage l'autonomie
ce report a fait une très grosse
batterie de 5500 milliards erreurs on
pourra voir un bloc de recharge rapide
de 50 watts délai videmment de la
recharge son fils qui a l'air et
beaucoup moins vite et aussi la recharge
d'un gars c'est pour venir charger vos
écouteurs pour venir charger un
adossement paul cette techno ont déjà
montré l'année dernière et ça marche
vraiment bien d'ailleurs
ça m'a déjà sauvé la vie dans un avion
le regarder des films sur mon smartphone
que mon siège était en panne que je
n'avais pas de charger en usb et que
j'avais mon écran poids pour recharger
bravo et merci oui arrive maintenant la
délicate question de l' os on aurait
sans ce smartphone android disent
effectivement dreux 10 de base mais sans
les services google tout ça qu'on aurait
sur une surcouche e et 8 10 on resterait
en gros dans ce qu'on connaît et dont ce
qu'on a déjà vu sur cette rencontre
sauf que cette fois ci on ne
bénéficieraient pas des sacs de google
exactement la même chose que ce qu'on a
sur le mec 30 pro alors c'est un petit
peu compliqué ou envoyés en train de
travailler pour développer ces au web
mobile service is c'est un peu
l'équivalent des services google mais
pour moi ouais le succès des services
dépendra complètement du fait et
beaucoup de développeurs qui développent
des applications spécialement pour le
oui est ce qu'il croit on va où est ce
qu'ils ont envie de paris nova way est
ce qu'ils ont et se dire ok on va
développer pour ios
on va développer effectivement pour
android mais maintenant on va également
développer pour moi ouais parce qu'on le
croit on va jouer et on croque va être
rentable pour nos applications qui est
un business à chercher du côté de chez
huawei donc tout cas ça on le verra dans
les temps à venir est ce que ce
smartphone va être bankable est-ce que
ce smartphone va être intéressant de par
ce pour la je sais je sais pertinemment
que vous il va nous faire un smartphone
purement énorme en termes de photos il
va aller très loin il va peut-être à
voir ce qui va arriver à la concurrence
mais peut-être surpasser les autres sur
certains points ce qui est sûr en tout
cas c'est que s'arrêtera smartphones
extrêmement innovant ce qui risque
d'être compliqué c'est vraiment toute
cette partie là qui est lié à android
comment ça va pouvoir passer est ce que
vous imaginez vous acheter un smartphone
en bénéficiant pas dupes les stores
c'est à dire pas gmail pas de youtube
paluku pour moi c'est quand même
relativement béton près de youtube pas
de google maps potes tout ça et ça pour
moi c'est quand même un petit peu
compliqué donc à voir comment vous et va
réussir à brignoles ce côté là toujours
est il qu'on ferait pas pour en arriver
harmonie où est cette année en tout cas
en europe
à voir ce qui va arriver en asie est ce
qu'ils vont intégrer harmonie s
alors je vous le dis la gamme pc la
gamme photo et c'est là où ça devient
extrêmement intéressant et c'est là où
on voit toute cette fiche technique il
commence à dessiner on aurait capteur
principal d'un grand angle à prioris 64
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 1.8
ça c'est ce qui semble se dessiner en
tout cas du point de vue des filles j'ai
du mal à imaginer qu effectivement
convenu propose uniquement un capteur de
64 mégapixels quand on voit que la
concurrence arrive sur des capteurs de
plus de 100 méga pixels est ce qu'ils
vont nous proposer un capteur de 100 8
mégapixels progrès technologiques à
pixels en un pour mieux fonctionner en
conditions de faible luminosité pour la
photo de nuit verra tout ça mais bon
minimum 60 4 mégapixels 500 est la base
de la base on aurait un ultra
grand-angle de 20 mégapixels un tel
objectif de 12 mégapixels avec un zoom
optique x 10 et on pourrait monter
jusqu'à un zoom hybride fois sans on
arrive avec le pétrin de pro à une
hybride jusqu'à x 53 50 vous y alliez
franchement la qualité n'était pas
complètement dingue las on arrive dans
le zoom et bridge et staff fois sans je
vous laisse imaginer la qualité qu'on
pourra par la case ou l'hybride x 50
à mon avis ça risque d'être extrêmement
bleus fond j'ai vraiment hâte de voir
tout cas les revenus de smartphones
alors il nous reste deux capteurs
j'imagine très bien une caméra t'offre
time of light qui vous permettra de
travailler pour le flou d'arrière plan
qui va mesurer en eau
la distance entre la caméra entre
l'objet et entre le reste permettra
d'abord des contours extrêmement nettes
et d'avoir un mode portrait qui est
quasiment parfait mais qui permettra
également certaines expériences en terme
de gaming quant au cinquième capteurs le
choix pour moi ce frais du côté de la
caméra macro alors la macro la retrouve
de plus en plus je suis pas convaincu
des usages mais pourquoi pas une macro
extrêmement bien maîtriser sa croissance
des usages relativement intéressant
pourquoi pas pour les instincts grammer
instagram eux vont partir et donc de 18
mm jusqu'à 240 millions pour couvrir et
donc quelque chose d'extrêmement là
avec tous ces capteurs que ça pourrait
être vraiment bien ton expérience photo
connaissant vos ouais je sais d'arrière
droit beaucoup d'intelligence
artificielle y aura beaucoup
d'optimisation logiciel ce qui vous
permettra d'avoir une expérience
complètement optimisé en termes de
photos alors on parle beaucoup de photos
bien mon avis il va en gros focus qui va
être fait en terme de vidéo
j'imagine que oui pour le proposer de la
vidéo jusqu'en 8 cas pourquoi pas comme
certaines rumeurs font état pour le
samsung galaxy s 20 ultra on pourrait
avoir de la vidéo en 8k à 30 images par
seconde mais très clairement ce qui
change c'est qu'on aura c'est là vidéos
en 4k à 60 images par seconde et
pourquoi pas aller aussi en terme de
qualité grâce à la stabilisation sur un
effet un petit peu gobron présenteront
smartphones se déplacer facilement
bouger et avoir une super starisation y
avoir un rendu vidéo ip ressouces c'est
vraiment un des points qui manquent
beaucoup sur les smartphones les photos
maintenant sont vraiment au niveau sont
vraiment top dans l'ultra haut de gamme
mais la vidéo il ya des solutions qui
sont intéressantes notamment sur le
dernier iphone l'iphone 11 pro 11 pro
mac
des résultats qui sont vraiment
extrêmement bluffant mais souvent la
vidéo c'est un petit peu le parent
pauvre
la silhouette pas dans ce sens là il
pourrait vraiment venir draguer les
créateurs de vidéos et d'optimiser
l'expérience et pourquoi pas mieux
positionné des micros pour bien capter
l'audio qui malgré tout reste quand même
un petit peu faiblard en terme
d'expérience bon bien évidemment on
aurait également un double flash led et
je vous ai dit un module photo à l'avant
avec deux caméras alors deux caméras oui
on aurait une caméra principale mme
honoré également un ultra grand temps qu
on y re rentrer tous vos potes
lorsqu'à beaucoup de monde et vous
voulez un petit peu pousser les murs
avoir effectivement comment tout ça va
dessiner comme owen va réussir à
intégrer tout ça mais je pense et
connaissant une fois de plus huawei la
r&d le boulot niveau derrière la vitesse
à laquelle ils avancent et qu'à mon avis
ils veulent vraiment venir marquer un
gros coup pour montrer aux quais
peut-être qu on nous bloque notre
histoire jeudi sur google mais croyez
moi ont déjà pu compter sur nous et dans
les années à venir pourra continuer à
être hyper concurrentiel mais on va
faire extrêmement mal l'un des très gros
enjeu chez huawei reste bien évidemment
la 5g wide open la 5g un peu partout
donc ce smartphone sera bien évidemment
5g compatible vous pourrez donc avoir de
la 5g
grâce à ce smartphone bien évidemment
une faute à singer sera déployée parce
que si elle est pas d pourriez vous
pourrez avoir un smartphone singer
compatibles ça ne marchera pas la 5g
c'est bien mais lorsque chez vous voulez
aussi une collection extrêmement rapide
j'imagine d'eau que ce smartphone sera
compatible wifi 6 je sais pas si vous
avez la fibre
si vous avez de la fir et vous avez du
wifi 5 et bien non juste un petit peu
bloquée par votre wifi
si vous passez directement office la
savate arty
et ça va carburer d'ailleurs j'ai fait
un test avec l iphone 11 promax avec la
nouvelle box de bouygues telecom eh bien
j'ai de la superficie brute en wifi sur
mon smartphone je suis quasiment à 1
giga et croyez-moi sa tartine vraiment
on aurait donc du wifi 6 du nfc une
certification ip68 résistant à l'eau et
à la poussière et du boot ou cinq points
mais ça je voulais déjà dit un
smartphone qui sera donc annoncé fin
mars à paris sa série chérioux le buzz
la division smartphones grand public qui
l'a dit à mes potes de frandroid
ailleurs frandroid grand coucou à vous
alors la date j'imagine qu'on portait de
tabler sur le 26 mars
fin mars une certitude donc on en
reparlera de ce smartphone vous en
parlerai je vous le présente très bien
évidemment au large et en travers on ira
faire des photos donc j invite à vous
abonner dès maintenant si ce n'est pas
déjà cas elle n'oublie pas devenir
actionner la petite cloche
qu'en est il du prix la douloureuse la
cuenta vous savez ce qu'il faut payer ce
qui fait toujours mal on voit qu on y va
toujours plus loin avant certains de
technologies continuent à être hyper
concurrencer côté du thb énormément
innover donc forcément le plus en fait
toujours ressentir un prix qui sera à
mon avis un peu à la hausse pas
énormément mais un peu à la hausse soit
modèle le plus haut de gamme smartphone
qui dépassera a priori les 1000 euros
dans la configuration elle la plus haut
de gamme et qui passerait par les canaux
classiques en france pour la
distribution sais pas si vous le savez
une aujourd'hui les smartphones se vend
le plus en france par les opérateurs
on devrait donc retrouver ce nouveau
smartphone de huawei chez vos opérateurs
bien qu'effectivement il n'est pas les
services google dessus et on devrait
aussi retrouver dans le commerce fnac
darty boulanger j'en passe et des
meilleurs qu'est-ce qu'on peut tirer
comme portrait robot avec toutes ces
informations mais tout simplement que
huawei continuer c'est une certitude ça
je mets ma main à couper à être énorme
en termes de r&d ils vont beaucoup plus
loin qu'il soit effectivement freiner
vous savez que en 2019
huawei une progression qui était
fulgurante énorme ils ont été coupées au
milieu de l'année avec cette histoire
liée à google entre les us une fois de
plus et la chine mais ça n'a pas bloqué
leurs 300 salles a ralenti et continue
d'avoir une croissance d videmment en
france mais aussi dans le monde entier
ou mango est donc un acteur important un
acteur majeur sur lequel on peut compter
maintenant mais encore plus dans les
années à venir une propose des device
qui sont vraiment énormes qui vont dans
le bon sens en tout cas du point de vue
consommateur y ait une vraie guerre qui
se joue entre les leaders le leader
journée c'est samsung ya huawei apple
est une vraie guerre qui joue pour
savoir qui sera le premier est très
clairement l'ambition de huawei c'est de
venir détrôner samsung pour arriver
numéro un du marché ça ça parle bien
évidemment de l'innovation technologique
mais ça ils savent déjà le faire ça
passera également par la réussite du
point de vue où est-ce parce que si
l'embargo américain continue et qui ne
peuvent toujours pas intégré les
services google
il va falloir qu'ils continuent à
développer et à miser sur leurs propres
solutions à voir si cela sera bon pour
le consommateur a dansé consommateurs
répondra à voir si les développeurs
répondront en tout cas ce un pari qui
est très intéressant sexus de
passionnant de voir comment la
géopoétique va venir vous bloquez les
beaux jours d'une entreprise et quels
sont les impacts le consommateur final
sans apparat très prochainement parce
que je veux faire réellement passionnant
avoir également table de technos que
l'apport nous propose la vie que oui il
est normalement d'un point de vue
technologique est ce qu'ils seront les
premiers à dégainer à vous proposer un
écran que la caméra intègre une caméra
invisible peut-être pas sur le paie 40
et 40 prompts à voir ce qui arrivera
peut-être sur la série mais également
leur mix le smartphone pliable de huawei
qui va arriver très très très
prochainement un peu revu et corrigé
enfin il ya une vraie belle revanche à
prendre de la part du web dit ok on est
là vous pouvez compter sur nous on va
vous impressionnait claude matos
vous proposez les solutions d'avenir
c'est vraiment hyper intéressant à
suivre du point de vue du consommateur
mais également notre position et nous
côté médias croyez moi c'est cool donc
on va suivre ça de très très très près
dites moi vous quelles sont vos attentes
concernant se paie 40 pro est ce que
vous pourriez vous laisser tenter par
toutes ces technologies photo vidéo
qu'est ce que vous en pensez qu est ce
que vous vous attendez et est ce que
vous pourriez vous laisser convaincre
bien qu'il n'y ait pas tardé google
marque pas tout ça en bas un commentaire
comme un nouveau coup dès demain et on
continue à parler take your man glamour
à demain
[Musique]
ce client
m
[Musique]